200 votre excitation suscité parce qu'en
fait mais j'aimerais bien voir tom
cruise maurice que j'arrivais en fin de
mois les gens me demandent des comptes
avec moi je voudrais voir tom cruise et
je vois là j'espère que je le croisais
dsk est ce que top games
awards
ou mardi non
howard
robin
aubert
vous êtes formidables un matin je suis
convoqué à 9 heures du matin la médecine
du travail donc à 20h45 un char de mon
immeuble bon c'est un petit peu tôt pour
moi j'étais pas très bien luné je sors
sur le trottoir et là il ya un gars qui
passe tout seul genre la région de côté
les cheveux collés juste de l'autre côté
genre serveurs de grandes brasseries
parisiennes
il me voit il
regarde on fait d'habiter ici je vous
aime pas je peux avoir un autographe
donc je pense qu'ils tournent encore
gelé satellisé voilà c'était tôt le
matin vous êtes formidables
mais
[Musique]
deux invités ça je sais que c'est pas le
moment mais deux invités pour toi c'est
à dire je peux faire entrer
[Musique]
expliquera j'en ai déjà une pleine tête
tiens j'ai pas commencé mon spectacle
meilleur buteur
dans le cinq
majeur dans le cinq ou six
dans le sac
ballon le sac aussi mais rendra à la
place on va mettre des tee-shirts